[Music]
my name is Wade watts I'd I'd pick that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny calm out of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go
[Music]
nowhere
[Music]
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
come to the Oasis for all the things
they can do
they stay because all the things they
can be can you feel this
[Music]
yeah the only place that feels like I
meaning the Oasis was the brainchild of
James Halliday Oh if you're watching
this I'm dead
I created a hidden object an easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible how the hell is he
winning
[Music]
- life-and-death stuff the Oasis the
world's most important economic research
there's nothing less than a war for
control of the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
[Music]
something
bigger than just myself
are you willing to
help us save the oasis
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters who destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the war we thought we finished is just
beginning and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
[Music]
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from who believed in you and who did it
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
my ball
drop
they evolved an egg-white after all life
I think these two this
[Music]
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty big
[Music]
[Music]
ditto
you
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all this time
[Applause]
run from it Dustin Stiller on
evacuate the city
engage our defenses
and get this vanish
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers and
balancing universe
[Applause]
with this
thus put a smile on my face
[Music]
the hell are you guys
[Music]
you
what's your name Laura sunny Croft
Laura your father's gone you can pick up
where he left off
I see so much of him in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tune called the
mother of death if Trinity succeeds our
world is in danger promise me you will
stop I promise I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it will be an adventure
death isn't hunted an adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here
but I'm glad that you did
what do you know about my father now I
see the lightness to recklessness close
the to once and for the fate of humanity
is now in your hands
[Music]
[Music]
don't be too careful these days the
world has gone bloody mad I'll take two
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in bout down
because we
because we own
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
so uh what are you dating like an
accountant our owen ventriloquist stop
ha you love a dummy this is not why
we're here
you try to show me I know why we're here
a rescue op save the dinosaurs from
island that's about to explode
what could go wrong
blue is alive you raised her I have seen
God's fly
the nanotech no weapon the other species
that I couldn't even imagine aliens
yeah guys we're here for
[Music]
if we're not careful
my son it is your time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's highlight for this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
George of seven feet weighed 500 pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay
this morning is nine feet pushing a
thousand
what's happening to my friend are you
familiar with genetic editing changes
will be incredibly unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf hello today huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's a big
mistake I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me going back
you have to evacuate Chicago George you
didn't ask for this they're gonna put
them down
that's not happening
there's something in that River
I was just thinking the only thing
that's missing right now is the giant
crocodile
[Applause]
[Music]
this morning I woke up in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait so how many of us are you
you
can you describe it's full no start from
the beginning what do you think I do
when you're away you think I'm out in
the garden pining looking at the sky I
gotta leave a day early
[Music]
your husband's here let me see him
he's extremely ill you have to tell me
why why is what he was doing it was his
decision to go in
something they termed the shimmer
they've sent in drones in teams of
people but nothing comes back but
something has you're a biologist who
served in the military if I do what
happened I could save his life
the boundary is getting bigger it's
expanding we're talking cities states
you need to know what's inside it's
beautiful check this out it's like
they're stuck in a continuous rotation
are they understand they're no sharks
have teeth like that it's not possible
you can't cross great difference bases
yes well soldiers on the last expedition
they went crazy or something here kill
them something's come to the face or the
fence we have to go back I can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroying
it's making something new
[Music]
you
you